Houston Police are investigating a gun
battle that left five officers injured
including four who were shot suspects
opened fire yesterday when police tried
to serve a drug-related warrant police
shot and killed two suspects
Mireya video is at Memorial Hermann
Texas Medical Center in Houston where
two of the officers are in critical
condition this morning midday a good
morning well good morning about a dozen
officers or so we're attempting to serve
a narcotics search warrant working off a
tip from a neighbor the suspects were
allegedly selling black tar heroin out
of that home and when they immediately
approached they were immediately met by
gunfire a barrage of gunfire erupted
around 5:00 p.m. when undercover
narcotics officers attempted a raid on a
southeast Houston home immediately upon
reaching the door the officers came
under fire from one or two suspects
inside the house police say the suspects
were armed with semi-automatic weapons
and then it stopped and then again there
was a total about maybe about 15 shots I
believe cell phone video captured two
officers running from the home there
goes what's why you shot shot unarmed
Houston police chief art Acevedo says
one of the officers had been shot in the
line of duty before he was there in the
front line said that doesn't tell you
about the heart or the men and women we
had the privilege to lead I don't know
what will according to the FBI the
number of law enforcement deaths by
weapons has increased and could climb 43
officers were killed in the line of duty
in 2017 compared to 53 last year in the
last five years 804 on-duty officers
have been killed president of the
Houston Police Officers Union joke
amaldi we are sick and tired of having
targets on our back we are sick and
tired of having dirtbags trying to take
our lives when all we're trying to do is
protect this community and protect our
families enough is enough
all morning long we have seen police
officers come into the hospital and show
their support this morning two officers
that were shot in the neck they were in
surgery they are out this morning but in
critical condition one wish on the
shoulder he has been released and two
more are in stable condition and
recovered here John Mireya thank you
made that recovery be speedy